is there uh weirdnesses to your own
sleep schedule as a scientist that
uh does incredible work has a lot of
things going on
has has to lead research has to write
research has to be a science
communicator
also have a social life all those kinds
of things is there
certain patterns to your own sleep that
you regret
or you um
or you participate in uh that you you
find you enjoy
um like is is there some like personal
stuff
uh quirks or things you're proud of that
you do in terms of your sleep schedule
the funny thing about
being a sleep researcher is that it
doesn't make you immune right to the
ravages of a difficult night of sleep
and i have
battled my own periods of insomnia in my
life too
and i think i've been fortunate in ways
because i know how sleep works and i
know how to combat insomnia i know how
to get it under control
because insomnia in many ways
is a condition where all of a sudden
your sleep controls you
rather than you control your sleep wow
yeah that's a beautiful way to put it
yeah
and
i
know when i'm starting to lose control
and it's starting to take control
and i understand how to regain
but i've it doesn't happen now
overnight it takes a long time so you've
struggled with insomnia yeah in your
life
i have not not all of my life i would
say i've probably had three or four
really severe bouts
and all of them
usually triggered by you know emotional
circumstances by stress
um stress that's connected to actual
events in life or stress that's
unexplainable
well
externally triggered yeah it's sort of
what we would call reactive stress
um
and
so that that's sort of point number one
about the idiosyncrasies the the point
number two is that when you are having a
difficult night of sleep
as a sleep researcher you basically have
become the woody allen neurotic of the
sleep world
because at that moment you know i'm
trying to fall asleep and i'm not and
i'm starting to think okay my
dorsilateral prefrontal cortex is not
shutting down my noradrenaline is not
ramping down my sympathetic nervous
system is not giving way to my parasite
at that point you are dead in the water
for the next two hours and nothing is
bringing you back so uh there is some
irony in that too i would say for myself
though i
if there's something i'm not proud of
it has been
at times railing against my chronotype
so your chronotype is essentially are
you a morning type evening type or
somewhere in between yeah and
there were times because society is
desperately biased towards the morning
types
you know this notion of the early bird
catches the worm
maybe that's true but i'll also tell you
that the second mouse gets the cheese
yeah so i think one of my
issues
around
you know is firstly people don't really
understand chrono type
because i'll have some people when i'm
sort of out in the public they'll say
look i struggle with terrible insomnia
and i'll ask them is it problems falling
asleep or staying asleep and they'll say
falling asleep
and then i'll say look if you are on a
desert island with nothing to wake up
for no responsibilities what time would
you normally go to bed and what time
would you wake up and they would say i
probably like to go to bed about
midnight and wake up maybe eight in the
morning and then i'd say so what time do
you now go to bed and they'd say well
i've got to be up for work early so i
get into bed at 10.
i say well you don't have insomnia you
have a mismatch between your biological
chronotype and your current sleep
schedule and when you align those two
and i was fighting that for some time
too i'm
probably
mostly right in the middle i am
desperately vanilla um unfortunately in
many aspects of life but this included
i'm neither a strong morning type nor a
strong evening type so ideally i'd
probably like to go to bed around you
know 11 10 30 11 probably somewhere
between 10 13 11 and wake up you know i
naturally wake up usually most days
before my alarm at um 704
um
and it's 704 because
why not be idiosyncratic in terms of
sitting i love it um
and so
i that's kind of awesome i've never
heard about that that's that's amazing
i'm gonna start doing that now setting
alarms like a little bit off the like
yeah i know i'm never quite sure why
we're the celebration of uniqueness
yeah and i am quite the the odd
snowflake in that sense too um
so i would usually then try to force
myself because i had that same mentality
that if i wasn't up at you know
6 13 in the gym by seven
that there was something wrong with me
and
i quickly abandoned that but if i look
back if there was a shameful act that i
have around my sleep i think it would be
that for some years until i really
started to get more detailed into sleep
um and now i have no shame in telling
people that you know i
will probably usually wake up around 6
45 naturally sometimes seven
um when people are looking at me
thinking you're a sloth you're lazy
um and you know i don't finish my
daily workout until you know i'm not
working until probably nine o'clock in
the morning i'm thinking what are you
doing now i will work late into the
day you know if i could i would work 16
hours that's my passion just like yours
so i don't feel shame around that but i
have changed my mentality around that
um it's complicated because i um
i'm
probably happiest going to bed at if i'm
being honest like at 5 00 a.m that's
fine you're just an extreme evening time
but
the problem is
it's not that i'm ashamed for it it's uh
i actually kind of enjoy it because i
get to sleep through all the nonsense of
like the morning and isn't that a
beautiful thing like people are busy
with their emails and and i just am
happy as a cow yeah and i wake up after
all the drama has been resolved yeah and
cows are happy and the drama has been
resolved exactly so i but you know in
society you do especially i mean this is
what i think about is um
you know when you work on a larger team
especially with companies
you are
you know everybody's awake at the same
time so that that's definitely that's
definitely been a struggle to try to
figure out just like you said um how to
balance that how to fit into society and
yet be optimal for your chronotype you
said yep
you have to sleep in synchrony with it
and harmony um because normally what we
know is that if you fight biology
you'll normally lose and the way you
know you've lost is through disease and
sickness
you said you suffered through several
bouts of insomnia
is there
aside from embracing your chronotype
is there advice you can give how to
overcome insomnia from your own
experience
right now the best method that we have
is something called cognitive behavioral
therapy for insomnia or cbti for short
and
um you work with for people who don't
know what it is you work with a
therapist for maybe six weeks and you
can do it online by the way i
recommend probably jumping online it's
just the easiest
and it will change your beliefs
your habits your behaviors and your
general stress around this thing called
sleep and it is just as effective as
sleeping pills in the short term but
what's great is that unlike sleeping
pills when you stop working with your
therapist those benefits last for years
later whereas when you stop your
sleeping pills you typically have what's
called rebound insomnia where your sleep
not only goes back to being as bad as it
was before it's usually even worse
for me i think i found a number of
things effective
the first is that i had to really
address what was
stressful and try to come up with
some degree of meaningful
um rationality around it
because i think one of the things that
happens there's something very talking
about conscious states to come all the
way back to um gosh i don't know i feel
like we've only been chatting for like
20 minutes but you're gonna tell me it's
been a while yeah it's been a while okay
i'm desperately i'm i feel like
terribly sorry okay but let's come back
to consciousness
where we started yeah um there is
something very strange about the night
that thoughts and anxieties
are not the same as they are in the
waking day they are worse they are
bigger and i at least find that i am
far
more
likely to catastrophize and ruminate
at night about things that when i wake
up the next day in the broad light of
day i think
it's nowhere near that bad man what were
you doing it's not that bad at all
so to gain firstly some rational
understanding of my emotional state
that's causing that insomnia it was very
helpful the second thing was to keep
regularity just going to bed at the same
time waking up and here's an
unconventional piece of sleep advice
after a bad night of sleep
do nothing
don't wake up any later
don't go to bed any earlier
don't nap during the day
and don't drink any more coffee than you
would otherwise
because if you end up sleeping later
into the the morning
you're then not going to be tired at
your normal time at night so then you're
going to get into bed thinking well i
had a terrible night of sleep last night
and yes i slept in this morning to try
and compensate but i'm still going to
get to bed at my normal time but now you
get into bed and you haven't been awake
for as long as you normally would so
you're not as sleepy as you normally
would be and so now you sit there lying
in bed and it's another bad night and
the same thing is you know if you go to
bed any earlier so don't wake up any
later
wake up at the same time
don't go to bed any earlier because then
you're just probably your chronotype
your biological rhythm doesn't want you
to be asleep and you think well it's a
terrible night i'm going to get into bed
at 9 00 pm rather than my standard 10
you're just going to be lying in bed
awake for that hour
naps will take our double-edged sword
they can have wonderful benefits we've
done lots of studies on naps for both
the brain and the body
but they are a double-edged sword in the
sense that
napping
will just take the edge off your
sleepiness it's a little bit like a
valve on a pressure cooker when you nap
during the day
you can take some of that healthy
sleepiness that you've been building up
during the day and for some people not
all people but for some people that can
then make it harder for them to fall
asleep at night and then stay asleep
soundly across the night so the advice
would be if you're struggling with sleep
at night don't nap during the day
but if you are not struggling with sleep
and you can nap regularly naps are just
fine
and we can play around with optimal
durations depending on what you want
just try not to nap too late into the
day because napping late into the day is
like snacking before your main meal it
just takes the edge off your sleep
hunger as it were but that would be um
so that's my unconventional
second piece of advice regarding
insomnia
the third is meditation
i found meditation to be incredibly
powerful i started reading about
meditation as i was researching that
aspect of the book
many years ago
and as a hard-nosed scientist i thought
this sounds very woo-woo um this is sort
of
we all hold hands and sing come by and
everything's going to be fine with sleep
i read the data and it was compelling i
couldn't ignore it
and i started meditating and that was
six years ago and i haven't stopped
and i found meditation before bed
incredibly powerful
the meditation app companies were
perplexed at this at first they want
people to meditate during the day but
when they looked at their usage
statistics they found that they would
have people in the morning meditating
and then there's a huge number of people
using the meditation app in the evening
what they were doing was self-medicating
this their insomnia and they finally
rather than railing against it they
started to see it as a cash cow
um
rightly so yeah so i found meditation to
be helpful having a wind-down routine is
the other thing that's critical for me i
can't just go from because when my mind
is switched on and i think you may be
like this too
if i get into bed
that rolodex of thoughts and information
and excitement and anxiety and worry is
just whirling away
and it's not going to be a good night
for me so i have to find a wind down
routine and that makes sense when you
realize what sleep is like sleep is not
like a light switch
um
sleep is much more like trying to land a
plane
you know it takes time to descend down
onto the terra firma that we call sound
sleep at night
and we have this for kids you know i
don't have children but you know a lot
of parents will say
you know we have to have the bedroom
sorry the bedtime routine you know you
bathe the kids you put them in bed you
read them a story you have to go through
this routine this wind down routine for
them and then they fall asleep
wonderfully
why do we abandon that
as adults we need that same wind down
routine
so
that's been the other thing that's been
very helpful to me so um don't do
anything different if you have a bad
night of sleep keep doing the same thing
manage your anxiety understand it
rationalize it
then meditation
and then finally having some kind of
disengagement wind down routine
those are the four things that have been
very helpful to me
you